je monte un truc qui est super drôle sur
un PC de Lenovo c'est sur le singbook
16p jenka regardez en fait vous avez
votre PC là et vous avez des petits
accessoires vous pouvez venir poser
votre webcam directement tac vous la
posez vous avez une webcam là mais si
vous voulez vous pouvez la twister comme
ça ça vous permet de filmer ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté sur le faire de la
visiocon avec une personne en face et
vous pouvez utiliser cette cam-là autre
truc qui est hyper drôle vous utilisez
ici ça c'est une petite LED pour venir
vous éclairer vous la poser vous appuyez
sur le côté tac un niveau on appuie
deuxième niveau troisième niveau hop on
appuie on déteint et puis le dernier
accessoire qui est assez marrant c'est
ça en fait ça c'est pour venir vous
connecter c'est du LTE donc probablement
4G 5g et vous pouvez bien connecté
directement ici votre PC lorsque vous
vous baladez et autre truc qui est très
cool c'est que vous le prenez et vous
pouvez venir le brancher directement en
USB C sur un autre appareil ça vous
permet de vous connecter partout où que
vous soyez truc qui est très marrant
c'est une nouvelle référence qu'on
trouve chez innovo alors le nom est là
on se parle bien du singbook 16p genkat
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
dites-le-moi d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires